hey guys so I realized I haven't been
that engaged in my social media or my
fan base online over the past couple of
years the reason I'm making this video
is uh just being totally honest I've had
some turbulent things been happening in
my personal life so I just didn't really
feel like being online uh and pretending
to be something I'm not when I wasn't
feeling like that Ed Sheeran is
on Tuesday the singer-songwriter got
candid with his fans on Instagram
addressing his recent absence from
social media I've had some turbulent
things been happening in my personal
life so I just didn't really feel like
being online and pretending to be
something I'm not when I wasn't feeling
like that and I know that sounds weird
but
and so making this video to say things
are looking up and I'm back online Ed
doesn't go into detail about those
turbulent things he mentioned but he
does flash his wedding band several
times during the clip so seems safe to
say he's not referring to his marriage
Ed tied the knot with his longtime love
Cherry Seabourn in 2019. their love
story goes all the way back to their
high school days
[Music]
in fact the singer has penned a few
ballads about his Leading Lady including
shape of you and perfect
[Music]
Jerry even starred in his music video
for put it all on me in 2019.
[Music]
the couple welcomed their first daughter
Lyra in 2020.
she's great she's walking she's talking
she's at my parents at the moment and uh
yeah what was her first word when she
started talking see I'm not sure because
she's been saying that for a while but
pointing at random so
um yeah I'm not sure and in May 2022 Ed
announced the birth of their second
daughter Jupiter writing on Instagram
that they are so in love with her and
over the moon back in 2021 Ed opened up
to Howard Stern about how fatherhood has
changed him for the better I think
becoming a dad
um just shifted my bedtime which then
shifted my uh waking up time which then
once you're up you're up and uh yeah so
I would get up with my daughter at like
five give her breakfast and then take
her in the gym and do a workout with her
and the Grammy winner added that while
his wife was pregnant with their first
daughter he cut back on drinking too I
probably open a bottle of wine at like 7
p.m at night right and then whatever
happens after that happens and you know
and then I got to the realization of
like what if cherries water breaks
tonight at 8pm and I can't drive her to
the hospital and I have to ring someone
and then they drive it I mean I would
feel like the worst husbands now Ed is
gearing up for the mathematics tour
returning to North America for the first
time in nearly five years and he
promises to bring that good content back
to our instagrids I'm back online
so um
yeah no
weird it's gonna start being posted here
I made this video like 50 times I'm not
making another one
[Music]